hemos tratado de hacer de eso nuestra fortaleza.
Pasamos la mayor parte del tiempo rompiendo cosas
y tratando de demostrar que estamos equivocados.
Eso es todo, ese es el secreto.
Primero, buscamos las partes difíciles del proyecto.
Con ánimo y entusiasmo decimos:
"Oye, ¿cómo mataremos nuestro proyecto hoy?"
Estamos en este equilibro interesante
que nos permite un optimismo irrestricto que aviva nuestras visiones.
Pero después también recurrimos a un escepticismo entusiasta
que da vida y pone un manto de realidad a esas visiones.
Quiero mostrarles algunos proyectos
que hemos tenido que dejar atrás en la sala de montaje,
y también algunas joyas
que por lo menos hasta el momento, no solo han sobrevivido al proceso,
sino que han sido aceleradas por este.
El año pasado cancelamos un proyecto de agricultura vertical automatizada.
Aquí vemos algo de la lechuga que cultivamos.
Una de cada nueve personas en el mundo sufre de desnutrición.
Por eso este es un sueño lunar que debe ocurrir.
La agricultura vertical usa 10 veces menos agua
y 100 veces menos tierra que la agricultura convencional.
Y como el alimento puede cultivarse cerca de donde se consume,
no es necesario transportarlo grandes distancias.
Hemos progresado mucho en áreas
como automatización de cosechas y eficiencia lumínica.
Pero, desafortunadamente,
no pudimos cultivar alimentos básicos como cereales y arroz de esta manera.
Por eso cancelamos el proyecto.
Este es otro problema enorme.
Pagamos enormes costos en recursos y daño ambiental
para enviar mercancías a todo el mundo.
El desarrollo económico de los países sin litoral
se ve limitado por la falta de infraestructura de transporte.
¿La solución radical?
Una nave de carga más liviana que el aire, de flotabilidad variable.
Tiene el potencial de reducir,
al menos en general,
el costo, el tiempo y la huella de carbono del envío
sin necesidad de pistas de aterrizaje.
Ideamos este sistema inteligente de avances técnicos
que en conjunto podrían hacer posible reducir lo suficiente el costo
de modo que podríamos hacer estas naves
suficientemente económicas en volumen.
Pero por muy económicas que fuesen en volumen
resultó costar unos USD 200 millones
el diseño y la construcción de la primera.
USD 200 millones es demasiado dinero.
Como X está estructurada en ciclos de retroalimentación apretados
en los que se comete errores, se aprende y se vuelve a diseñar,
no podemos gastar USD 200 millones
para conseguir los primeros datos
sobre si vamos por buen camino o no.
De haber un talón de Aquiles en uno de nuestros proyectos,
queremos saberlo ahora, rápidamente, y no al final del camino.
Por eso cancelamos este proyecto, también.
Descubrir un defecto importante en un proyecto
no significa terminar el proyecto.
A veces eso nos lleva por un camino más productivo.
Este es el prototipo de nuestro vehículo completamente autoconducido,
que hemos construido sin volante ni pedal de freno.
Pero ese no fue nuestro objetivo cuando comenzamos.
Con 1,2 millones de muertes en carreteras en el mundo cada año,
construir un vehículo autoconducido era un sueño lunar natural a seguir.
Hace tres años y medio,
cuando probamos estos Lexus, modernizados, autoconducidos,
les fue tan bien, se los dimos a otros empleados de Google
para averiguar qué pensaban de la experiencia.
Y descubrimos
que nuestro plan de tener autos que se condujeran solos
y solo pasaran el control al usuario en caso de emergencia
era un plan realmente malo.
No era seguro
porque los usuarios no hacían su tarea.
No estaban atentos
en caso de que el auto necesitase que tomasen el control.
Fue una crisis importante para el equipo.
Volvieron al tablero de diseño.
Y se les ocurrió una nueva y maravillosa perspectiva:
Un auto en el que uno es verdaderamente un pasajero.
Uno le dice al auto dónde quiere ir,
presiona un botón
y el auto lo lleva a uno del punto A al punto B.
Estamos muy agradecidos
de haber tenido esta idea tan al principio del proyecto.
Ha dado forma a todo lo que hicimos desde entonces.
Y ahora nuestros autos han autoconducido más de 2,24 millones de km,
y salen a la calle cada día
en las calles de Mountain View, California y Austin, Texas.
El equipo de autos cambió su perspectiva.
Este es uno de los mantras de X.
A veces cambiar la perspectiva es más potente que ser inteligente.
Veamos la energía eólica.
Es uno de mis ejemplos favoritos de cambio de perspectiva.
No hay manera de construir
un aerogenerador estándar, mejor que los expertos de esa industria.
Pero nosotros encontramos una forma de llegar más alto en el cielo,
y así acceder a vientos más rápidos y consistentes,
y a más energía sin necesidad de cientos de toneladas de acero para llegar allí.
Nuestro cometa de energía Makani se eleva
haciendo girar las hélices a lo largo de sus alas.
Y saca una correa de sujeción conforme sube,
llevando energía a través de la correa de sujeción.
Una vez que la correa está extendida,
atraviesa el viento haciendo círculos en el cielo.
Y ahora las hélices que lo elevaron son turbinas de vuelo.
Y envían la energía por la correa de sujeción.
Todavía no hemos encontrado la forma de cancelar este proyecto.
Y cuanto más sobrevive esa presión, más entusiasmo nos genera
de que pueda convertirse en una forma más económica y desplegable
de energía eólica para el mundo.
Quizá el proyecto que parezca más loco es el Proyecto Loon.
Estamos tratando de llevar Internet en globos aerostáticos.
Una red de globos en la estratósfera
que lleva una conexión a Internet a las zonas rurales y remotas del mundo.
Esto podría poner en línea a 4000 millones de personas más,
que hoy tienen poca o ninguna conexión a Internet.
Pero no es solo tomar una antena de telefonía móvil,
fijarla a un globo y ponerlo en el cielo.
Los vientos son demasiado fuertes, y podrían volarse.
Y los globos están tan altos que no es posible atarlos a tierra.
Ahí llega el momento de la locura.
¿Y si, en cambio,
dejamos que los globos vayan a la deriva
y les enseñamos a navegar vientos para ir adónde tienen que ir?
Resulta que la estratósfera tiene vientos
que van a muy diferentes velocidades y direcciones en estratos delgados.
Esperamos que con algoritmos inteligentes y datos de los vientos del mundo,
podamos maniobrar los globos un poco,
haciendo que suban o bajen solo un poco en la estratósfera
para que atrapen esos vientos que van en diferentes direcciones y velocidades.
La idea es tener suficientes globos
para que cuando un globo se vaya de su zona,
otro globo esté listo para flotar hacia ese lugar,
tomando el relevo de la conexión a Internet,
así como los móviles pasan entre celdas
mientras uno va por la carretera.
Entendemos lo loco que suena esa visión
y de ahí que el nombre del proyecto nos lo recuerda.
Desde 2012,
el equipo Loon ha dado prioridad al trabajo que parece más difícil
y por ende es más probable de cancelar el proyecto.
Lo primero que hicieron
fue tratar de obtener conexión Wi-Fi desde un globo en la estratósfera
hacia una antena en la tierra.
Funcionó.
Y les aseguro que había apuestas a que no iba a funcionar.
Así que seguimos andando.
¿Podríamos hacer que el globo hablara directamente a los teléfonos,
así no necesitábamos la antena como receptor intermediario?
Sí.
¿Podría el globo tener un ancho de banda suficientemente alto
para una conexión a Internet real,
para poder brindar algo más que solo SMS?
Las primeras pruebas no eran de más de un megabit por segundo,
pero ahora podemos transmitir hasta 15 megabits por segundo.
Suficiente para ver una charla TED.
¿Podríamos hacer que los globos hablen entre sí en el cielo
para llevar nuestra señal a lo profundo de las zonas rurales?
Verificar.
¿Podríamos mantener en vuelo globos del tamaño de una casa más de 100 días,
y que cuesten menos del 5 %
del costo de fabricar globos tradicionales de larga duración?
Sí. Al final.
Pero les aseguro, que hemos probado de todo para llegar hasta allí.
Hicimos globos redondos, plateados.
Hicimos globos gigantes con forma de almohada.
Hicimos globos del tamaño de una ballena azul.
Reventamos muchos globos.
(Risas)
Dado que una de las cosas que quizá cancelaría el proyecto Loon
era que no pudiésemos guiar a los globos por el cielo,
uno de los experimentos más importantes fue poner un globo dentro de otro.
Hay dos compartimentos aquí, uno con aire, otro con helio.
El globo bombea aire hacia adentro para hacerse más pesado,
o expulsa aire para hacerse más liviano.
Y este cambio de peso le permite subir o bajar,
y ese simple movimiento es su mecanismo de dirección.
Flota hacia arriba o abajo,
esperando captar vientos que lo lleven en la dirección y la velocidad deseadas.
Pero ¿es lo suficientemente bueno para navegar por el mundo?
Apenas al principio,
pero cada vez mejor.
Este globo en particular, nuestro último globo,
puede navegar un tramo vertical de cielo de 3 km
y puede navegar hasta menos de 500 metros de donde se quiere ir
partiendo a 20 000 km de distancia.
Nos falta mucho por hacer
en términos de puesta a punto del sistema y reducción de costos.
Pero el año pasado, un globo construido a bajo costo
dio la vuelta al mundo 19 veces durante más de 187 días.
Así que seguiremos adelante.
(Aplausos)
Nuestros globos hoy
están haciendo casi todo lo que tiene que hacer un sistema completo.
Estamos en conversaciones con telefónicas de todo el mundo,
y vamos a volar sobre lugares como Indonesia
para dar servicio real de pruebas este año.
Quizá todo esto suene demasiado bueno para ser verdad,
y tienen razón.
Ser audaz
y trabajar en cosas grandes y arriesgadas
pone a la gente intrínsecamente incómoda.
No se le puede gritar a la gente y obligarla a fallar rápidamente.
La gente se resiste. Se preocupa.
"¿Qué será de mí si fracaso?
¿La gente se reirá de mí?
¿Me despedirán?"
Empecé hablando de nuestro secreto.
Me despediré contándoles cómo hacemos para que suceda.
La única forma de hacer que la gente trabaje en cosas grandes y arriesgadas
-- ideas audaces --
y hacer que realicen las partes más difíciles del problema primero,
es si uno hace que eso sea la vía de menor resistencia para ellos.
Trabajamos arduamente en X para que sea seguro el fracaso.
Los equipos cancelan las ideas tan pronto como haya evidencias sobre la mesa
porque se les recompensa por ello.
Reciben aplausos de sus pares.
Abrazos y saludos de sus gerentes, yo en particular.
Son promovidos por eso.
Hemos dado bonos a cada persona de equipos que cancelaron proyectos,
desde equipos de 2 personas a equipos de más de 30.
Creemos en los sueños en la fábrica de sueños lunares.
Pero el escepticismo entusiasta
no es enemigo del optimismo ilimitado.
Es el socio perfecto del optimismo.
Libera el potencial de cada idea.
Podemos crear el futuro que está en nuestros sueños.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)